Fox News Alert at this hour we are
tracking multiple breaking stories the
president holding a rally pretty raucous
in Iowa tonight oh and Joe Lee got 75
people quid-pro-quo Joe we're going to
take you there live in just a moment
plus we are continuing to monitor the
question and answer phase of the
impeachment charade yes that is going on
as we speak will dip in and out as
warranted but first tonight the
president has every reason to be glad
and happy because it's about to be game
over but what is the Democrats latest
scheme by all accounts Chuck Schumer the
Democrats do not have the votes to keep
this going any longer today he said it
would be an uphill fight to call
additional witnesses now keep in mind
this is very important the mob and the
media won't tell you during Clinton's
Senate trial there were no new witnesses
called none Jay Sekulow pointed out all
the witnesses called in the Senate were
previously deposed in the house
proceedings or grand jury proceedings
still you have the compromised corrupt
congenital liar Adam Schiff desperate
he's now actually begging and pleading
for just a few days of new witness
testimony which again like everything
else he's done is unprecedented but look
at your screen in the opening week on
the Senate floor well shift stated that
the charges quote had been proved in
fact he is the exact phrase that have
been proved over and over again well his
colleague Jerrold Nadler said quote
rock-solid case they have now for
impeachment so if they prove their
rock-solid case why couldn't they get a
single Republican in the house and why
are they now begging Senate Republicans
to literally take over what is the
constitutional role the sole power of
the House of Representatives to impeach
why would they give that to them and get
this even quid pro quo Joe Biden that's
right he got it right and he argued this
in 1999 in a trial memo quote that no
additional witnesses or evidence were
needed in order to acquit Wow
hypocrisy abounds ABC reporting the
witch-hunt the trial could be over by
either tomorrow or Saturday and what
weaken has been for the past four days
and nights the president's legal team
has absolutely obliterated and destroyed
the Democrats bogus case including one
particular moment and actually there
were many where the corrupt congenital
liar
Adam Schiff he was ripped to shreds by
the president's personal attorney Jay
Sekulow watch this we're talking about
now
additional witnesses that the managers
have put forward and that Democratic
leader Schumer has discussed he's
discussed four witnesses in particulars
if this body would if it were to grant
witnesses would say yes you get those
four witnesses and the White House and
the President's Council gets what
whatever I want that's what you said mr.
Jim whatever I want here's who I want I
want Adam Schiff I 100 Biden I want Joe
Biden I want I want the whistleblower
they put this forward in an aggressive
and fast-paced way and now they're
saying we now we need witnesses after 31
or 32 times you said you proved every
aspect of your case that's what you said
well you did he said he just said he did
well then I don't think we need any
witnesses checkmate game over Democrats
argument is almost now too sane
too insane to be true again they claim
that their rock-solid case totally
proved them but we want you to bring in
about a half a dozen new people more
witnesses people we didn't even call or
subpoena to prove our case in addition
to the 18 previous witnesses spouting
hearsay an opinion there was only one
fact witness of all their witnesses
remember what he said what do you want
mr. president nothing no quid or pro or
quo like Joe have you ever heard
anything so stupid in your entire life
even Nancy Pelosi
she's now beginning to see the
handwriting on the wall and she is
apoplectic and furious and even
beginning a meltdown take a look the
president's team is there to dismantle
the Constitution of the United States
and some of them are even lawyers well
he will not be acquitted you cannot be
acquitted if you don't have a trial and
you don't have a trial if you don't have
witnesses and documentation and and that
I would I don't think they made the case
I think they disgraced themselves
terribly in terms of their violation of
what our Constitution is about and what
a president's behavior should be
detached from reality again pretty scary
rage-filled Fantasyland the president
will never be acquitted
well this is why voters well they see
through the charade and all of this is
but the culmination of a three-year long
non-stop never-ending temper tantrum by
Democrats who still cannot accept the
will of the American people from 2016 it
is only the latest redundant chapter sad
chapter in the left's never-ending smear
campaign against the president as they
do nothing for the American people we
have witnessed this kind of feign phony
selective outrage hypocrisy every second
minute hour of every 24-hour day this
has never been a fact-finding mission or
about the truth at all because it's been
run by somebody who's lied to the
country for three consecutive years a
fact witness in this case himself he's
compromised the congenital liar we have
all the proof we need on Russia Russia
no we don't and today like every day
pretty much
they spewed more lies including a
brand-new totally insane conspiracy
theory let's take a look at the latest
one let's say Rudy Giuliani does another
errand for the president this time an
errand in China and he says to the
Chinese we will give you a favorable
deal with respect to Chinese farmers as
opposed to American farmers we will
betray the American farmer in the trade
deal but here's what we want the quid
pro quo is we want you to do an
investigation of the Biden's you know
the one the one the president's been
calling for they would say that's okay
they would say that's a quid pro quo to
help his reelection he can betray the
American farmer that's okay oh wait he's
the guy that said quid pro quo Joe who
said you're not getting the Billy unless
you fire the prosecutor investigate
my zero experience son being paid
millions they were totally innocent and
he's fantasizing now about his favorite
anti Trump analogy on the Senate floor
as he refuses to even discuss the
origins of the witch trial the fake
whistleblower that he lied about in that
case case you forgot this whole ordeal
allegedly starting because a stunning
and brave deep state bureaucrat came
forward with an urgent warning about
President Trump and by we'd love to hear
from the whistleblower he said this
individual files a complaint with the
Intel community's Inspector General and
in the subsequent weeks shift vowed to
bring this person in for important
testimony he said we have not spoken
directly to the whistleblower we would
like to speak to this person and then
everything changed because he got
exposed the like well was revealed and
it's surfaced in reports that the so
called hearsay whistleblower was in
direct contact with his office from the
get-go even before the complaint was
filed and all of a sudden yes the
congenital liar refuses to allow this
individual to testify in the house and
even more importantly he was stopping
and refusing you want documentation he
won't release the inspector general's
report surrounding this individuals
complaint and now he refuses to address
any questions about another report
claiming that the whistleblower oh it
was actually overheard as an Obama
holdover two weeks into the Trump
administration early 2017 discussing
with another fellow deep state Obama
holdover how to get rid of Trump and
despite a mountain of evidence about the
fake hearsay whistleblowers political
bias and seedy connections and
connections to congenital Liars office
apparently he's a delicate flower he who
must not ever be named Lord Voldemort
the whistleblower he shall never be
named he shall never face any questions
about his motives even Chief Justice
Roberts well he did the Democrats
bidding today pretty shameful in my view
and refused to read a question well that
possibly contained the alleged identity
of the hearsay non whistleblower
whistleblower that was in touch with oh
ship Sophos from the get-go and make no
mistake as the president
he's pointed out this here say
whistleblower has a lot to answer for we
will get answers one day take a listen
if the whistleblower as is alleged in
some public reports actually did work
for then Vice President Biden on Ukraine
issues exactly what was his role did he
have some reason to want to put the
deep-six on any question raising any
issue about what went on with the
Biden's in burries m''e and firing
Chokin and withholding a billion dollars
in loan guarantees and enforcing a very
explicit quid pro quo you won't get this
billion dollars until you fire him what
company would ever pay millions of
millions for somebody with no experience
what vice president would ever demand
and use our tax dollars a billion of
them and shake down the country to fire
a prosecutor and you only got six hours
and son of a B they did it be careful
what you wish for Adams ship because if
additional witnesses are called well not
only will your precious hearsay
Whistleblower get name but you will be
called in to testify by the way either
way quid pro quo Joe zero experience
hunter being paid millions with no
experience you know and this little dog
and pony show will end with even further
embarrassment either way those things
must be investigated they must be at
this point no matter what the president
will be vindicated we are now just 278
days until the ultimate jury you the
American people yep you get to have an
opportunity you can shock the world
again presidents picking up momentum
moments ago we had this to say about the
entire impeachment charade let's take a
look you know we're having probably the
best years that we've ever had in the
history of our country and I just got
impeached can you believe these people
they want to nullify you balance poison
our democracy and overthrow the entire
system of government that's not
happening I can tell you that that's
only a matter of time before the
Schumer's shift sham show was over and
the president he's already winning at a
great new article Molly Hemingway at the
Federalist identifying eight key reasons
why the Schumer ship sham show is a big
win for the president and a big loser
for Democrats one it is clear he did not
commit any impeachable offense no more
even identified the articles don't list
the impeachable offense second democrats
have botched this charade from the
beginning weird soviet-style top secret
investigation in the basement of the
House of Representatives no due process
for the president and his lawyers weak
pathetic evidence hearsay witness's
opinion witnesses second third hand
account witnesses and a convoluted
series of accusations that were
difficult to understand first quid pro
quo no we'll call it bribery no we won't
mention any of these things and the
actual articles third the Democrats they
got zero Republican support none
whatsoever
remember of Nancy Pelosi said it has to
be bipartisan not bipartisan four we
have the inexplicable one month delay
sending impeachment to the Senate a word
of advice for Nancy Pelosi if you got a
ram through because it's so urgent two
Bs articles of impeachment record time
and not subpoena the witnesses that you
now think maybe you should have
subpoenaed all the name of urgency you
might not want to procrastinate
transmitting the articles to the Senate
because it kind of makes it look like
you're lying because you did it just
before Christmas because it was urgent
so you could go on vacation and then you
go on vacation you still don't want to
hand them over
Howard's it wasn't five the president's
defense team all credit be do they have
done a spectacular and an amazing job
top to bottom and six house managers
have done nothing but insult senators
and we the American people never-ending
non-stop lying
outright innuendo and by the way
everything we've gotten for three long
years as they have done nothing but hate
this president and not serve the
American people or do anything for peace
prosperity job creation nothing and the
safety of the American people seven the
Cavanaugh style last minute coordinated
smear tactics that they thought would
work they have not been successful and
eight this entire charade cemented what
we have already known about the mob and
the media they're deranged they had
nothing but an extension of the radical
extreme Democratic Party socialists and
they have been rooting against this
president every step of the way this is
almost impossible but news busters has
reported their study it's pretty
breathtaking Network Evening News get
this gave a hundred percent negative
spin coverage of all the president's
defense that is winning the day and a 95
percent positive spin on oh you know the
congenital liar and the Democrats
arguments do you want to know why I
called the media the mob there you go
without a doubt one of the mobs favorite
targets has been Harvard constitutional
law professor scholar Alan Dershowitz
and it has been brutal it has been
vicious he is a Democrat he is quite
knowledgeable about our Constitution
he's met a professor at Harvard for a
long time and listen to what because he
dares have a different opinion listen to
what they say we have the new catechism
of the new legal Oracle Dershowitz legal
catechism that nobody has ever embraced
of stature
I don't think Harvard is happy tonight
the only thing that Alan loves more than
the law is the TV camera that's amazing
when you lose your hair what happens
this is an American this is what you
hear from Stalin this is what you hear
from Mussolini what you hear from
authority from Hitler from all the
authoritarian people who rationalized
you know and some cases genocide based
on what was in the public interest
muzzle Eenie
Hitler genocide Alan Dershowitz is
driving the mob off a cliff because of
facts reason intellect and something
called the Constitution